>> I came from Bonn, from Germany, and with
my colleague Tom Arnold,
we want to briefly talk about Haiti.
One of my first jobs was in Haiti in the early
1980s.
I worked on poverty and hunger and agriculture.
I was deeply impressed by Haiti's rural communities,
what they did with
meager resources, investing in the health
of the children and their
education.
But I was -- as many are -- deeply depressed
by government's situation
of the country at that time.
Tom, my colleague, just comes back from Haiti,
and is one of the best
sources on what's going on now and how you
can help.
>> Yes, I came back from Haiti.
I visit Haiti 4 to 5 days after the earthquake.
I visited there because I feel concern about
our organization has been
working in Haiti for the past 16 years.
So when I was there, our immediate issue was
how to get and how to make
our contribution to the immediate needs of
the people.
I was deeply struck by their dignity and calm
in a terrible situation.
Our focus was get water to people and beginning
to look at shelter
situation and on getting food.
And that has remained our focus in the intervening
ten days.
I think at this stage, the international community
is beginning to get
its act together on the aid front, and I think
they should appear at
the World Economic Forum to bring together
the Clinton Global
Initiative and the UN and the World Economic
Forum is highly
commendable.
[INAUDIBLE] short term needs more [INAUDIBLE]
and the NGOs for the
medium to longer term goal on getting more
invest to Haiti this
initiative is extremely vital.
>> What I learned in Davos, Tom, is that other
than many of the media
reports, those who have been on the ground
were deeply impressed by
good government engagement and NGOs and civil
society.
So I think those who have donated money, resources
and have thought
about Haiti, can feel a lot better then about
the aid reaching the
poor.
>> Yes, I think some of the early comments
from the press in the few
days after the disaster were, I would say,
unfair.
I think there was not sufficient accounting
of the scale of the
devastation that effected the country in terms
to the damage to the
government, both physical and the people and
the physical
infrastructure, the whole communications systems
were completely
knocked out.
So there was a huge task.
It was inevitable, I think, it was going to
take a little time to start
get the aid flowing.
That has now I think begun to happen.
Although certainly not fast enough.
There's a real need to get food or general
distribution of food to the
population.
But, you know, that's where the challenge
faces, the NGOs on the ground
faces, the UN agencies to really work effectively
together and I that
is -- and I'm confident that is happening.